dans un des épisodes de big bang theory
le dr sheldon flash cooper se prend pour
flash et court à une vitesse proche de
celle de la lumière vers le grand canyon
la question à laquelle j'aimerais que
l'on réfléchisse aujourd'hui c'est que
voix
sheldon flash cooper et ça c'est une
question fondamentale qui va nous amener
à parler de la théorie de la relativité
restreinte d'albert nuit avant de faire
des expériences de pensée avec sheldon
cooper et leonard dhruv t'adore
j'aimerais vous faire réfléchir un petit
peu à l'état de la physique à l'époque
d'albert einstein
à cette époque là un physicien très
connu lord kelvin aurait dit que la
physique était finie qu'il n'y avait
plus rien à découvrir
alors je doute pas mal qu'il ait dit ça
puisqu'il a sans doute remarqué lui
aussi que les deux grandes théories de
la physique de l'époque était en fait
contradictoires d'un côté la théorie de
la mécanique par isaac newton dit que
toute vitesse et relatives en
particulier le fait de ne pas bouger
c'est à dire avoir une vitesse égale à
zéro est un fait relatif de l'autre côté
on a la théorie de l'électromagnétisme
par james clerk maxwell qui dit elle que
la vitesse de la lumière est absolue
bien sûr la plupart des physiciens de
l'époque avait remarqué cette
contradiction payante entre ces deux
grandes théories mais leurs solutions
préférentiel consistait à supposer qu'il
existait un référentiel absolue soit ce
pont des à ce qu'ils appelaient les
terres par rapport auquel la vitesse de
la lumière de la théorie de maxwell est
démesuré question fait les changements
dans les faits rancière avec la théorie
de maxwell ici on essaie d'observer les
thèses et lumière avec un autre
observateur et ben les équations reste
inchangé et on vous tient toujours la
même vitesse de la lumière
et c'est complètement repenser le monde
se demander s il
test de lumière était vraiment absolue
comme le disent les équations de maxwell
quelles en seraient les conséquences et
il est prêt à sacrifier tous qu'on prend
pour acquis pour pouvoir garantir le
fait qu'une case la lumière est le même
pour tous et en particulier ce qui va
sacrifier c'est le caractère absolu de
l'espace et du temps
ça ça veut dire que pour certains
observateurs l'espace et le temps seront
différents de ceux qu'il est ce
justement pour sheldon flash cooper qui
va des vitesse faramineuse par rapport à
nous et qui donc un référentiel qui
complètement différent du nôtre
l'espace et le temps et pas franchement
le même que celui que l'on voit que l'on
ressent on pense cela faisons une
expérience de pensée
imaginons que l'on mesure le temps à
l'aide d'un rayon de lumière qui va de
base en haut puis de haut en bas dans un
sabre laser
à chaque fois que le rayon de lumière
atteint le bas un tic va être jouée
donnant ainsi le rythme du temps
imaginons maintenant que sheldon flash
cooper france au sabre laser avec lui
lorsqu'il court au grand canyon dans son
référentiel puisque le sabre laser ne
bouge pas par rapport à lui sheldon bois
la lumière push et à la verticale mais
pour leonard hofstadter rester chez lui
ce qu'il voit c'est une lumière bouger
en diagonale c'est parce que pendant que
la lumière va de haut en bas et de bas
en haut
le sabre laser qui le contient lui
bouche de droite à gauche
ainsi la distance que parcourt la
lumière entre taux tic est plus grande
dans le référentiel de leonardo que dans
celui de sheldon or einstein a postulé
que la vitesse de la lumière était
absolue et donc forcément elle va à la
même vitesse pour sheldon comme pour
leonardo
si elle a pu parcourir plus de distance
selon leonhardt que selon shell 2
c'est donc forcément car il s'est passé
plus de temps entre deux tic dans le
référentiel de léonore cul dans celui de
sheldon plus de temps s'est passé entre
deux événements pour le dans l'offshore
c'est que si elle une montre sur lui ça
montre tout n'aurait plus vite que celle
de sheldon cooper
mais ça veut dire que le temps ait accès
pour les retours fiat or si on oublie
sheldon
enfin la situation est la même pour les
oiseaux flatteur du coup pour lui la
montre tourne normalement ce que ça veut
plutôt dire c'est que s'ils regardaient
la montre de sheldon cooper il aurait
l'impression qu'elle tourne moins vite
que ce qu'elle devrait que tu as une
montre qui la lui
autrement dit le temps ou plutôt les
durées semble dilater pour les objets
que l'on voit en mouvement
c'est fou que juste là en parlant en
quelques minutes seulement et en partant
de seulement du postulat quelle vitesse
la lumière était la même pour tous
on a déduit juste là que le temps n'est
pas le même pour tous qu'il n'ya pas de
temps universel c'est complètement fou
que ya d'autres conséquences assez folle
de l'hypothèse souvent like à la vitesse
de la lumière est la même pour tous
prenons un autre exemple celui de la
simultanéité imaginons que sheldon flash
cooper court toujours à huit est proche
de celle de la lumière et que cette fois
il a un double sable laser qui tient
horizontalement comme ça et on va
imaginer qu'il allume du coup le rien de
hier par des deux côtés de façon
simultanée est atteint du coulée de boue
a privé selon charlotte de à un moment
simultanée aussi que voix leonard
hofstadter lui voit sheldon avancer à
une vitesse proche de celle de la
lumière
eh bien puisque qualitel lumière est la
même pour tous ce que voilées ou d'un
proche catr de son référentiel c'est que
les deux rayons de lumière partent en
même temps qu'ils vont à la même vitesse
mais pendant qu'ils se propage dans
l'espace schengen lui se déplace
légèrement et du coup un bout du sabre
laser s'est rapproché du rayon lumineux
alors que l'autre bout du sabre laser
c'en est éloigné nous pour parler en
termes un petit peu plus technique
l'événement que l'on définit pas la
lumière atteint un beauf du sabre laser
versus la lumière atteint l'autre bout
deux événements selon leonard hofstadter
n'arrive pas en même temps ne sont pas
simultanée alors qu'il n'était pour
sheldon cooper
autrement dit le concept de simultanéité
devient maintenant relatif
il n'y a pas de simultanéité absolue
quoi il ya juste une simultanéité qui
est gros l'atvs préférentielles dans
lequel on observe l'univers et ça aussi
c'est flou c'est complètement con plus
intuitif mais c'est juste une
conséquence
deux hypothèses sont la qualité de la
lumière est la même pour tous vous allez
me dire mais tout ça ça a l'air
complètement fou c'est juste pas
possible que ça soit vrai on n'observe
pas ça en pratique
ben là je vais vous renvoyer vers un
troisième vidéo de ma série sur la
relativité celle sur et développement
limité pour vous dire que tout ce que
l'on voit est une approximation eu la
théorie de la relativité restreinte que
l'on a le droit de faire parce que l'on
vit à des vitesses très éloignée de
celle de la lumière
on avance quasiment pas à pas avoir
invité au vitesse de la lumière du
couple avaient ajouté les vitesses asim
planifié quasiment vrai qu'on est
quasiment absolu et tout ça
peut-être plus exemple plus pratique que
moi du coup vous voulez peut-être une
preuves plus tangibles de ces dilatation
du temps et relativité de la
simultanéité et pour cela je vais vous
parler des mieux qu'il soit un type de
particules quand les particules
cosmiques se rapproche de la terre donc
ils sont environ 1 des vitesses proches
de celle de la lumière quand elle
rencontre l'atmosphère plein de
nouvelles interactions qui apparaît il
ya plein de nouvelles particules qui
sont créés et l'une de ces particules
est le mur est donc le mur on est créée
très haut dans l'atmosphère terrestre et
ils se rapprochent ils tombent vers la
terre sauf que la durée de vie du mime
est très faible
en fait énormément elle est beaucoup
trop faible pour pouvoir parcourir la
distance entre le haut de l'atmosphère
ou à les créer et le sol donc a priori
surtout si l'espace et le temps sont
absolus le mieux on ne va pas assez vite
et ne vit pas assez longtemps pour
atteindre le sol de la terre pourtant on
observe des millions à la surface de la
terre
pourquoi eh ben la raison lancé un
dilatation du temps truc seniors en
effet les murs ne vivent pas si
longtemps mais comme ils vont à des
vitesses très proche de celle de la
lumière
le temps est dilatée pour eux si on
mettait une montre au poignet dormions
que ce n'est pas faisable mais bon
imaginons qu'on ne fait pas cette montre
tourne aurait très lentement
une vision que la montre est tel que
lorsqu'elle fait un tour le mur on meurt
vinci où on était dans le référentiel du
mieux ben on verra cet compte retourner
très vite
mais comme le mur va très vite pas porno
à des vitesses proches de celle de la
lumière
cette montre l'atome créneau hautement
carl haub certes on est très lentement
et du coup ça donne plus de temps dans
notre référentiel pour le mur le mieux
on vit plus longtemps dans notre
référentiel que dans le sien et ça ça
veut dire qu'en fait dans notre
référence et il a le temps lui de
parcourir cette distance entre le haut
de l'atmosphère et le sol est là si vous
avez bien suivi
vous devriez me demander oui mais qu'est
ce qui se passe si on se place
maintenant dans le référentiel du mur
parce que dans le référentiel du mur le
mur lui ne vit que le temps utile dit
quoi du coup la montre tourne
normalement et du coup il n'a pas le
temps pour parcourir la distance entre
l'aude nous faire le sol est là là là il
faut s'acheter juste incroyable ce que
neil stein c'est que en effet vous êtes
tout à fait raison mais dans le
référentiel du mur distance sans
contracter comme j'en ai déjà parlé dans
l'épisode précédent le distincts sont
donc à quai dans la direction du
mouvement
ça veut dire que pour le mieux la
distance entre le haut de l'atmosphère
et le sol est beaucoup plus petit que ce
que nous on pense et c'est pour ça que
l'union dans son référentiel lui il a le
temps de parcourir cette distance
parce que bon il n'a pas beaucoup de
temps mais il a beaucoup moins de
distance à parcourir en fait la
dilatation du temps va venir être
parfaitement compensé par la contraction
de l'espace de ce soir qui est plus
aucune cohérence et que tous les
référentiels sois consistant les uns
avec les autres
tout ça einstein vais étudier il a
développé les mathématiques qui
l'écrivent tout ça avec précision et l'a
publiée en 1905
dans un papier qui juste révolutionne
notre vision de l'espace et du temps et
pour en revenir au mieux ce que le muon
voix pendant une fraction de seconde
c'est une terre aplati houran entier et
ça c'est exactement ce que voit aussi le
dr sheldon flash cooper quantique ou à
une vitesse proche de celle de la
lumière
c'est à ces clauses j'aimerais vraiment
voir ça moi aussi j'espère que vous avez
aimé cette vidéo je vous propose pour la
première fois un défilé
oui c'est un jeu de mots pourri et le
défilé d'aujourd'hui consiste à résoudre
le paradoxe suivant imaginons que l'on
veuille capture est celle d'un flash
cooper dans une cage lorsqu'on vous
pourrez vouloir faire c'est prendre une
cage qui fait exactement la largeur de
la taille de shannon cooper maintenant
s'il sheldon flash cooper 28s proche de
celle de la lumière dans notre
référentiel qui va dessus de la cage ce
que l'on voit c'est un sheldon cooper
allen vitesse très proches habitent et
de lumière mais coup les distances sont
contractés pour challes donne du coup
chaîne va nous paraître plus petit qu'il
ne l'est dans son référentiel et du coup
ils devraient être particulier plus
petit que l'accueil du coup on devrait
pouvoir d'en fermer sans problème mais
si on fait maintenant le raisonnement
dont le référentiel de shannon c'est la
cage qui va à une vitesse proche de
celle de la lumière
du coup c'est la cage qui est contractée
dans le sens du mouvement
du coup la cage devrait plus petite que
la taille de sheldon dont le référentiel
de shannon et du coup on est amené à
conclure une chose et sont opposés en
fonction du référentiel dans lequel on
réfléchit d'un côté dans notre influence
elles ont l'impression qu'il est
possible d'emprisonner sheldon alors que
deux doses sont essentiels sheldon a
l'impression qu'il est impossible de le
mettre en cage
et ça c'est un paradoxe comment le
résoudre
parce que vous avez une idée mettez ça
dans les commentaires tu t'es moi ça ou
envoyez moi sur facebook et dans
l'épisode suivant je signalerai les noms
des personnes qui ont su résoudre le
défi les la prochaine fois on va
continuer avec la relativité restreinte
et notamment avec le corollaire ou la
conséquence du de cette relativité
restreinte qui est la fameuse formule e
égal mc carey la question à laquelle
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez
pendant ce temps c'est qu'est ce que
signifie cette merveilleuse équation
willems et kalou je suis sûr qu'ils ont
déjà entendu parler
d'ici là si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
ben ali qu'il a commenté la partagez la
sur les réseaux sociaux
tu vois sur facebook twitter
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et j'espère que
je vous verrai la prochaine fois le
passage du temps aussi quelque chose
quelque chose de relatif il va falloir
une toute nouvelle théorie de l'espace
et du temps